Let's talk about Donald Trump's tax returns.
Briefly.
The situation with Donald Trump's tax returns
is escalating to the point where Donald Trump
is now effectively begging the Supreme court
to hide his tax returns from investigators.
And this is hilarious, but it's also very
important in terms of what is quickly becoming
a battle, really about the separation of powers
in the United States and about checks and
balances.
So I'll catch you up and then we'll get to
the news.
Investigators have a criminal probe going
into Donald Trump and his businesses finances.
They've tried to obtain Donald Trump's tax
returns and his business tax returns for this
investigation.
Trump tried to block it.
Multiple courts have already okayed it.
The next step is the Supreme court.
And indeed Donald Trump has filed for an appeal
to the Supreme court.
Now, what's important with the Supreme court
is they're not required to take the case at
all.
They're not required to review the ruling
of the lower court.
In this case, it's the second district court.
The Supreme court might decide we're not going
to take the case.
Um, and in that situation, the lower court
ruling would stand, which in this particular
situation is a ruling that says Trump has
to provide the tax returns to the investigators.
Importantly, the Supreme court currently has
to Trump selections, Neil Neil Gorsuch and
the absolute lunatic Brett Kavanaugh.
The Supreme court is going to announce in
the next few weeks if they will review the
case if they agree to review the case.
That review probably will happen before the
2020 election.
Now there is breaking news on this.
The Supreme court did yesterday impose an
indefinite delay, uh, on the house of representatives
demand for president Trump's financial records
to give them time to figure out how to handle
the dispute until they decide what is going
to happen with this case, that case.
The other case related to Donald Trump's taxes,
but this is a major separation of powers case
because if the Supreme court does take the
case and they decide, you know what, Trump
does not have to turn over his tax returns,
what does that say about our checks and balances?
The checks and balances in our system?
What does it say about Donald Trump's ability
to or not to have to obey prevailing laws?
It also relates to this issue of Donald Trump's
immunity.
Trump's lawyers claim that Donald Trump has
immunity, not just from prosecution, but even
from investigation.
That is a very loose reading of any law that
you can find.
And a big piece of all of this is going to
come down to that because remember, we were
told, and even Robert Mueller said at the
conclusion during his testimony and and in
the Mueller report, that he did not take a
position on whether Donald Trump should be
indicted on obstruction of justice because
it is the policy via memo.
It has not been legally tested, but it is
the policy via memo of the justice department
not to prosecute a sitting president.
That's layer one.
We could, we could argue that.
We could debate that there is this further
position that Donald Trump's lawyers are trying
to argue that Donald Trump's taxes and his
business taxes should not be provided to investigators
in New York.
Why?
Because Donald Trump is immune even from investigation.
And I have read no seriously legal opinion
that agrees with that.
And then of course we go back to the bigger
picture on the merits.
Anybody working this hard to hide their tax
returns has something to hide that is very,
very serious.
We don't have to go through that.
Once again, I don't believe that Donald Trump's
taxes would expose criminality, although arguably
a double accounting and one set of books for
loan purposes and one set of books for tax
purposes in New York state is actually against
the law.
I believe the most likely scenario is that
Donald Trump would be exposed as not being
as wealthy as he claims to be.
I believe that Donald Trump's shady business
dealings, which are the subject of much speculation
with all sorts of different countries, could
be Russia, Saudi Arabia and others would potentially
be exposed.
And uh, it would be both, uh, personally embarrassing
to Trump and also problematic for him.
I don't know that it's a shoe in that there
is actual criminality or at least definitive
criminality that would be exposed by Trump's
tax returns.
Although I certainly wouldn't rule it out.
And it wouldn't come as a surprise given everything
that has gone on.
So my questions to you.
Number one, why do you believe that Donald
Trump has been working so hard for so long
to prevent the release of his tax returns?
Number two, what do you believe will ultimately
happen with this case and the release of Trump's
taxes?
Will the Supreme court take the case?
Let me know what you think.
Remember to get on the David Pakman show newsletter@davidpakman.com
on black Friday.
If you are on that newsletter, you will receive
an email with a very special discount code
useful only on black Friday for a major membership
discount at the David Pakman show.
You need only sign up for our newsletter@davidpakman.com
we will take a quick break.
I have interesting video for you coming up
next, we will talk about the schedule for
the show for the rest of the week because
there is a lot going on and a very interesting
voicemail still to play
for you.